[Music]
mentors love giving back makers love
helping how to figure out what the next
best step would be when you have a
jillion things on your list of things
that you need to do when you're feeling
something you have to go off and do that
thing even when it doesn't make logical
sense because it's your heart talking
and your heart is the thing that will
guide you forward welcome to another
morning show how can I help what do you
got I'm looking at a few people that I
think are amazing for music industry
mentorship okay how do you approach a
mentor how how do you word things is it
like do you have is there that stupid
dance that people always talk about not
stupid but like I mean a relationship is
a relationship I'm just curious about
how to start those kind of yeah
so this is one of the most important
lessons I think mentors love giving back
mentors love helping I think people are
built to serve humans that serve again
you find satisfactions and serving
others if you're not happy in life
you're not serving people enough yeah so
mentors love to serve the problem is
most mentees don't do the work and so it
it becomes a waste of time okay
and people who had success hate wasting
of time that's the thing that they love
a lot it gives them a lot of
satisfaction yet it wastes their time
most of the time yeah so that's the
constant battle that mentors face and
want mentees so the best way to get in
is for you to not ask for someone to be
your mentor because that applies it
applies a relationship let me point up
on a blind date hey will you not even
like when you're married what you're
doing right it implies that you're not
you're not respecting the relationship
enough to go in right away and say will
you be my mentor okay the best thing to
do is go and ask one question you got to
find your way in to ask one quick a yes
one question is this so like you're
talking somebody in the music industry
what is the most important question that
you want answered and then take that
question and then go do something about
it right right okay so it's how do you
get in so there's a lot of ways in you
might they might be speaking in the
venting you go find them have
before they speak not after because
after they get bombarded with hay they
might be doing it
Instagram live uh-huh find them right it
might be it might be trying to DM them
and is showing the hustle right right so
I had I had a woman who who was emailing
me he said I love that ask you one
question about my business would mean
the world to me
even if it's even if it's while you're
walking to your car right on the
freezing Tuesday morning those are the
time all days and you're like oh and
I'll bring I'll bring you coffee you
know yeah I'll bring snacks yeah it's
like it shows whether that is the actual
scenarios in matter
it shows the heart yeah it shows the
hustle you gotta love a hustle thank you
and so showing that eagerness and
ambition is a thing because what you
want is that person to see themselves in
you like you're now a younger version of
they've gone off and done right right
doing whatever it takes to get on that
person's radar and then asking one
question I got one question and then go
do the thing do it and then who's either
it's gonna work and then repeat yeah
well you just gonna work and then you
come back the greatest thing of all for
any mentor for me is to know that the
advice that I gave was active it worked
right and then yeah about it yeah right
like I want to see your empowerment I
want to see the woman down I want to see
like picture you with all the women who
woman bounce they're like yeah yeah
right see and then you share that you
share that but it may also not work like
it may not work the advice maybe was bad
advice or you just didn't fully
understand the advice or processing
properly where most people what they'll
do is they'll look at it they'll either
won't do anything about that advice
it'll try wantin it doesn't work and
then they go back with the second
question yeah what happened to the first
one yeah don't come back with a second
question until you did something on the
first frame either come back and tell me
it worked and now you're ready to go to
the next step or come back and say I
tried when you gave me but not just once
you try to like a hundred times
yeah and it's just I can't I wanted I
want to do the thing that you gave me to
do when I tried it and here's everything
yeah and then it's the effort that
matters not the result but you took it
that is so hard to learn oh my god I
can't tell you
yeah yeah for was for your own happiness
and life but for ya mentorship it's yes
that you acted on the advice yeah and
you tried your best so I want to see the
hustle and then come back for a second
and then then then you're building a
relationship right so you want to get in
get that first question in do the work
come back then with either follow up on
in fat success or you tried it a
thousand times and it didn't work right
and then you want some clarification
okay right yeah that's that's what it
sounds like it would be the another
conversation exactly and now you're
being mentored yeah yeah okay that makes
sense
thank you how to figure out what the
next best step would be when you have a
jillion things on your list of things
that you need to do to get to that one
big big goal how do you decide for me
it's always uh sorry I'd leave with the
heart okay as you grow and as you have
more success and as you start building a
team and have lots of things around you
your to-do list and your ideas list will
only grow mm-hmm right thank you any
more like my ideas list it's always
growing probably a million times a day
right yeah
this giant Evernote file please from
like some ten years ago but it only
grows like you never get all those
things done great doesn't have so to
chew yeah and then even launching this
show I it up in priority and now bump
all the other things that I had to do
and other ideas at the bottom of the
list yes so I don't think you should
ever attend your goal I don't think you
have a five big bowl I think if you
think you four five your go-to thinking
small mmm I think you're cheating
yourself in five years I want to be here
I think you might hit that goal but it's
nothing compared to what you could be
yeah and so I only have a lifetime goal
that's never gonna happen
it's so big that's beyond me and then
what I'm doing well
right if you want to have a successful
recording career there's a lot of ways
to get there yeah yeah the best way to
me the ones that you engage fully and in
love yeah yeah so I look at my list and
then feel what feels best and then go
off on the right thing
all right it's simple right like it
sounds is it look like who's our head
tox is down it really does it really
does
and even in the time of thinking about
which of the things you should be doing
you could have already done yeah most of
those things yes right and so what I
love doing is really shortening the gap
between idea to action idea to action
idea that I did go out idea go out and
instead of making some big giant thing
make it the smallest possible thing so
what we tend to do is entrepreneurs we
get an idea I want to be recording
artist awesome to do that I need to have
this any that this and this and this and
this and then it just becomes this giant
thing that there's no way you can do
yourself and you give investors and you
this is impossible and it's fun it's a
it's a fun exercise here dreamers and we
see the future and like we're optimistic
and we want to build a better way yeah
it says fun living in that that land but
then it become so overwhelming that then
what are you doing you may not even like
singing oh yeah how about you try
singing right right and so yeah so do
don't find the smallest possible way to
just start and then see if I like it if
you like it I know where to go from it
right like starting the show I just I
just started it I didn't have a
microphone and then on the first the
first couple of it was like hey we can't
hear you
great that you get a microphone right
this is how I start things right so
you've got 24 people my team but I'm the
only one here yeah and if this grows to
be this giant show then then they'll be
tell me more people lots of stuff around
it but I'm here setting up myself tripod
in the camera I'm here trying to figure
out the wires and it's all tangled up
yeah but that's how we spike it's a
small awesome way to start a ground up
yeah you start and then you then you see
like you might get into one of the
things on your list and be like you know
this this feels like I'm pulling teeth
like I hate this mm-hmm great don't
spend all day doing that like pick the
next thing great because there's lots of
ways to get to where you want to go when
you're feeling something you have to go
off and do that thing even when it
doesn't make logical sense because it's
your heart talking and your
the thing that will guide you forward
your head will help you figure out how
to do it but most people most people's
heads work against them for them saying
you can't do that it's like no I'm doing
this help me figure out how to do it
yeah so which one of your of your 18
things are on your list should you do
mm-hmm
leaning into one that you're feeling the
most and go off and do that thing and
you'll build so much momentum on it and
it'll help you in ways that you don't
even know realize or complain for right
you still use your head heart says you
need to do it we're gonna do it you're
talking that you're preaching that quiet
yeah I know help me figure out how to do
it yeah if you want to learn five ways
to find mentors check out the video link
right there next to me I think you'll
enjoy it continue to believe and I'll
see you there the question was how do I
suggest attracting mentors into my life